when you were cast in Jurassic world did
they because this is a big part of being
in one of these movies is you need to be
able to scream yes you need to be able
to scream as if you're seeing a
genetically mutated Tyrannosaurus Rex
yeah chasing you do they obviously
you're a very well-known and respected
actor but did they check out first
whether you had a good scream cuz that
would be important yeah that would be
important they did not they didn't
that'd be so funny if they committed to
this eight hundred million dollar movie
hired you and you're terrific and then
you see the dinosaur you like but I have
to say they they got lucky they took a
good guess you have a good screen I have
a really good scream I have a really
good scream do you mind if we come on
cuz something you could do right now I
can do it right now okay I'll be turned
around I'm the person you fear the most
in the world oh wait a minute I just
realized I have this okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
that made me love you